hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this tutorial i'll
actually be giving you a quick uh a
brief explanation of the youtube
uh in inbox glitch which has been
plaguing a number of more popular
youtubers uh who seem to be the only one
who have a problem with it but uh here's
here i'll go over actually the way i uh
manage it and the way it actually works
and i can still answer and receive all
new messages and i'm sorry guys
questions so here's how i do it up here
at the top you'll see i have 68 new
messages which is in fact wrong but i'll
click on this anyway and you'll see that
i have
right here no new messages in this
folder i have deleted all the new
messages so that whenever a new message
does come in you'll actually tell that
it is not highlighted so that's the only
problem with the youtube messaging uh
this glitch that's going on right now so
if you do go to your new messages and
you look none of them will be
highlighted so it'll look like none of
the none of them are new but in fact all
the ones on the top in fact the 68 that
would be on the top would be old and the
ones that are on the very top above
those are actually new so if i do get a
new youtube message it'll show up as the
only message here i'll reply to it i
will delete it and then the new messages
that come in they won't be highlighted
but they'll still be there so that's how
i cope with the youtube messaging glitch
i hope this quick tip helps you guys so
i know it's a nice way to come back
after a few days off and um yeah that's
basically it now shared with you i do
delete all shared videos and um so if
anyone were to share a video with me
right now it would be not highlighted
but it would be the only one there so
yeah that's that's how i message that's
how i manage with the glitch and i hope
this helps you guys who are actually
struggling with it unable to answer
messages so um thanks for watching this
video and
hope it helps peace
you